I've been saying for years if you
believe that Democrats and Republicans
are the same on every issue you are
truly very seriously wrong but it is
true that on lots of issues there are
really no practical operational
differences between Democrats and
Republicans and one of those areas is
basically what I call the default
unquestioning funding of the military
industrial complex and defense spending
many times merely questioning whether we
should continually spend more and more
money on the military and defense merely
asking the question is considered
unpatriotic some right-wingers would
have you believe that it's bordering on
treason to question military and defense
spending and the Democrats mostly are
complicit yet again 89% of the Democrats
in the Senate have helped Republicans to
pass another huge perverse depraved
expansion of the military
despite the reality that we already have
a bigger military than we could ever
possibly need 700 billion additional
dollars have been approved for the
military over the next ten years this
would give the American military a
larger budget than they had at any point
during the entirety of the Iraq war and
the Afghanistan war and this past eighty
nine to eight eighty nine to eight these
sometimes democratic hero John McCain a
Republican senator was at the forefront
of asking for more money saying if we
don't grow the military if we don't feed
it more money we risk losing our edge
over the militaries of other countries
there are still some details here to be
sorted out but actually getting the
money to the military is more or less
the only one otherwise that this is
going to happen and the Democrats are
right there in the house back in July
about 60% of Democrats voted in favor of
this and now 41 41 out of the 46
Democratic senators voted in favor that
is more than 89% of them here's some
real bipartisanship right Republicans
and almost all Democrats can agree let's
give even more money to the military
this is why progressives aren't happy
with the Democratic Party
among countless other reasons
progressives need to see the Democratic
Party sort of as a tool in the shed or
an arrow in the quiver not as the path
to a more progressive country because a
huge portion of the Democratic Party on
some really major issues cannot be
counted on to do the progressive thing
and in the meantime by the way 700
billion for the military once you're
talking about 700 billion dollars
you're talking about numbers big enough
to maybe fund Bernie's freak so-called
free college program that was going to
cost something like 47 billion a year
this is 700 billion over nine or 10
years you're talking about not being
able to afford better health care
covering everybody but on a whim you can
expand the already most expensive
military in the world right when you
talk about universal health care or
maybe free college everyone asks how are
you going to pay for it but you don't
have to give that justification when it
comes to increased defense but no oh if
you ask the question you're doing
something wrong by asking and all you
have to say is well you know this this
affords us the other freedoms that we
have right because we have such a strong
military we have to pay for health care
and free college and everything else and
then there's never a follow-up there's
never a follow-up there's never any
serious conversation about it and the
other question I have for the Democratic
senators is Republicans didn't really
need this many Democratic votes couldn't
some Democrats have voted against this
on principle or are even the Democratic
senators afraid that they will be cast
as unpatriotic by their opponents when
it's time for their own re-election
campaigns that's probably part of it
because they were going to pass this but
I think it's because this new version of
the NDAA stalls Trump's transgender ban
so maybe some Democrats thought of that
as a worthy enough concession to pass
the 700 billion dollar bill give another
700 billion but you stall not stop the
transgender ban that's interest an
important issue but it's just not good
enough it's not good and and of course
there's no reason these things have to
be connected as always with American
politics and and the the bottom line is
the problem that applies to mostly all
senators is that the military-industrial
phlex does create jobs right giving 700
billion extra dollars to the military it
will maintain some jobs contractor jobs
weapons manufacturers jobs and maybe
it's tough for these Democratic senators
to go back to their districts
particularly ones and this isn't
everybody but it's many of them that
have these contractors and companies in
their districts and explain why now a
hundred against another 700 billion
dollars for the military the entire
system is the problem here well much
like on health care with this we've
learned that politics makes strange
bedfellows yeah I guess while there was
opposition from the left like Bernie
Sanders Patrick Leahy there was also
people on the right like Michael Lee and
Rand Paul opposing this so maybe even
though we've lost the center there's
some hope on the fringes I don't know
that the the overlap between the more
libertarian Republicans and some
progressives has existed for a while but
it only exists on some issues right so I
get what you're saying yeah there are
some people in the Republican Party with
an R next to their name that will
overlap with some progressives on these
issues but they're not really people
that can be counted on big picture to
advance a progressive agenda and I think
that's the important thing to keep in
mind the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership